[Musique]
le compte twitter de goomba suspendu et
cette fois ci ce n'est pas à cause d'un
clash entre rappeurs ça va pas tarder à
partir en couille sérieusement non le
duc de boulogne aurait selon le réseau
social enfin les conditions
d'utilisation en utilisant une photo de
dark vador en guise de photo de profil
je suis ton père une justification peu
plausible selon le rappeur qui accuse
twitter de censure concernant son
dernier poste l'heure est grave mes amis
suite à mon post d'hier sur twitter
montrant nos chefs d'état en flagrant
délit de mensonge concernant l'antidote
mon compte a été bloqué en effet
quelques heures avant booba avait publié
une vidéo dénonçant la stratégie
vaccinale du gouvernement'' quand vous
êtes vacciné ne risquait pas de
contaminer les autres alors simple
coïncidence ou volonté de boycotter les
propos de l'artiste quelles sont les
vraies raisons
bon ben c'est vous qui a été censuré
pour ses propos oui c'est un nouvel
exemple qu'aujourd'hui quand vous postez
quelque chose sur le coup vite sur
réseaux sociaux vous êtes clairement
censuré vous avez plus de chances que
vous faites de vous faire censurer qu'on
vous poster un tweet anti-vaccins qu'un
truc raciste par exemple c'est n'importe
quoi et là où ils sont bêtes les réseaux
sociaux ces camps sont sûrement les
propos anti max il alimente les théories
du complot voilà des gens qui disent
qu'à raison une dictature parce que
désolé mais ne pas pouvoir dire ce qu'on
pense c'est une dictature dont je trouve
ça nul voile c'est incroyable ce qui est
arrivé à booba qui il vers des noms mais
ces foules là c'est la liberté
d'expression qui est bafouée il est
censuré on a l'impression que parce
qu'il dit des choses qui vont contre les
idées du gouvernement l'empêchent de
parler qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays
qu'est ce que c'est que ce réseau social
je suis tout coeur avec boubet c'est
vraiment scandaleux cependant le rythme
en tout cas ça va lui faire plaisir vous
souhaitez
vous adore merci c'est martin je connais
pas trop mais vous avez quand on voit
toutes les toutes les conneries cas sur
twitter tout les trucs tous les trucs
moches et les photos les vidéos qui
circulent sur twitter qui s'oxyde en
appelant à l' matthieu delormeau il va
faire son émission sarah meier ville et
là aussi je vais le censurer comme le
cas et là on explique juste une photo de
dark vador mais à combien c'est humilier
au
cc du mito et bien sûr mais ça mais je
vois je reviens à ce que dit guillaume
arrêtez de faire des choses comme ça
parce que ça alimente justement le
complot et comme par hasard quand ils
ont vu toutes les réactions qui a eu sur
twitter parce que tout le monde a été du
côté de booba ah bah finalement on 30 on
compte non en fait on quand vous avez
votre compte pour votre photo de profil
on est là
en fait en décalage
la semaine dernière je me suis aussi
positionné dans l'émission et après à la
suite de ça je suis allé voir sur
internet les articles je pensais qu'il
sera en ma faveur vu le nombre de
messages hyper positif que j'ai reçu des
français est en fait c'est en plein
délire elle est en séance de paranoïa
est les machins elle sort du cadre elle
elle dérape donc en fait aujourd'hui la
presse fait passer les gens qui sont en
s'interroge santé ben oui qui
s'interroge effectivement vous
interrogez on les décrédibilise
totalement et on les bloque donc c'est
grave alors je vais donner à paris mais
après on défonce à non non non je suis
sûr vous donnerez votre avis parce
qu'ici tous les avis sont ouais ouais on
est bien mieux même si booba est un de
mes amis proches vous savez que j'aime
beaucoup vous pourrez donner votre avis
ouais donc avec toute la liberté qu'il
soit moi bien entendu rien vous sera
retiré ouais rien ne vous sera rajouté
vous pourrez venir dîner à la maison ah
oui bien sûr voilà mais venez a remis
ça mais on arrive à la limite de
l'exercice dégâts femmes c'est à dire
c'est une entreprise privée csu pense
que les gars ou à l'usure
décide qui décident de ce qu'elle peut
censurer ce qu'elle peut pas censurer ce
qui est la vérité poète qui n'est pas la
vérité pour elle donc voilà on arrive un
vrai moi je pense que c'est un vrai
enjeu de société parce que normalement
on doit pouvoir dire ce que l'on veut y
compris des choses avec lesquelles les
autres ne sont pas d'accord je suis
désolé alors ça ton sens de la loi à ce
moment là les arts et les autres vont
porter plainte j'aimerais bien avoir
l'avis de mathieu voilà je vous dis
mathieu comme courageuse et le sol qui
mais non non mais je vais donner demain
un jour j'étais assis à côté lui et je
lui dit bouba pourquoi vous avez
toujours des propos homophobes dans vos
chansons et me répond je suis artiste et
alors ce qu on est artiste
dit la vérité non mais non mais
arrête de dénigrer tout non non non non
tracée après mandat mais c'est un très
bon pote à moi arrêter
amélie et marées voulait être à côté de
mathieu je me souviens pourquoi mais
parce qu'ils avaient des il avait déjà
eu des propos pas du tout arrête de dire
des conneries arrête un peu marre et
d'histoire mais arrête n'en mettais
toujours en train de tout essayer de
trouver des trucs aussi d'attaquer les
uns et des autres il a dit pourquoi tu
pourras tu poses on parle de twitter là
tu viens de nous parler d'une histoire
récente en termes ce n'est pas quand
même il faut que j'aie des débuts sans
attendre le ces la fin on s'en fout de
toi tu rapportes toujours tout à toi on
te parle d'un truc sur les réseaux
sociaux tulipes ou by many ça j'adore le
boîtier vous dira pourquoi on ne sera
pas les barrages on va pas eh ben je te
jure voilà pourquoi nous sommes là le
début de l'histoire s'est passée pas
pour ramener à moi c'est pour te dire
qu'il dit je suis artiste donc on peut
tout dire non quand on est parti et on
peut passer tout dire je voulais dire ça
c'est on peut pas tout dire on abat
pardon fauquet nos traductions sinon on
va rien dire alors je vais dire ça
n'arrête pas d'introduire toi arrête un
peu
au final c'est pas parce que tu as tu es
ce que tu peux tout dire il a une
responsabilité il ya plein plein de
mômes qui le regarde et je trouve que
aujourd'hui mais s'en prendre aux
banques la droite ok je peux plus il a
raison booba saint génis
mais
toi tu es bien aux gens d'aller se faire
vacciner 3 oui je ne suis pas un artiste
mais arrête de dire des conneries
réseau nos caisses de résonance takuma
d'abonnés et ouais c'est là combien
d'abonnés à tous je sais pas 2 millions
sur twitter ouais bah alors telle caisse
du réseau pas de bêtises donc quand tu
dis allez vous faire vacciner toi aussi
tu donnes ton avis pourquoi lilas palois
donner son avis et parce que justement
je n'ai pas donné j'ai pas dis ouf avec
ci n'était pas marqué sur twitter et
comme l'avait très bien du hadj à
fabrice di vizio autour d'une table ce
sont des mots que tu les écrits on va à
propos vente non mais mais les ruptures
gagnent quand on n'est pas de ton avis
tu es dur comme cyril j'ai dit la même
chose à gilberte alerte a bien été dur
contre agit sur tf1 celui qui est pas
celui qui est dur quand on n'est pas de
son avis et toi je te le dis et en plus
cette attaque toujours aimé et tu
respectes pas d'éloges c'est lui qui m'a
taillé rapporte toujours toi toi même
sortir moins intéressante pourquoi sur
twitter on aurait le droit de mettre des
vidéos qui dure 15 minutes sur le fait
que les gens doivent se vacciner fait
que le vaccin est formidable qui sauva
deux balles de match devant vous et
pourquoi on n'aurait pas droit d'avoir
une autre version de gens qui dirait pas
moi le vaccin je m'en méfie parce que
j'ai peur parce que marche pas parce que
troisième d'autres experts acceptant une
fois laissé les deux versions sinon
c'est ce que c'est géré à saper la chine